developing this morning metro police
investigating a murder in the west part
of the valley
a father allegedly shot and killed by
his son
near cimarron and alto last night we
have hector mejia live at the scene with
the latest hector good morning good
morning john and we are told the son
surrendered himself to police and it was
not immediately clear whether he'll face
any charges and the scene here right
behind me just cleared
just a few minutes ago we know
investigators got a search warrant
overnight to begin
processing the scene here in a home
right behind us
and according to homicide detectives the
father who was shot and killed
was the suspect in an earlier domestic
violence incident
that father accused of attacking his son
around six last night in a home near
cimarron and alta
well the son called police at the time
but when police arrived the father had
taken off
at some point the father returned to the
same home
and around 10 p.m police got a second
call from the son
this time it was to report a shooting
officers arrived the son surrendered to
the officers
and the male father was pronounced
deceased at the scene
at this point it's still very early on
we're interviewing the people who are in
the house to include the
wife of the deceased and also the wife
of the
son police are sorting out
exactly what led up to the shooting the
father was in his late 40s
with this being the week between
christmas and new year's it's a
tough situation for this family we are
told the sun is cooperating police were
checking the history between everyone
involved as they
try to sort out what happened here right
behind us reporting live near cimarron
and alta hector mejia
8 news now